[موسيقى]
بينك
هكذا ردد الاطفال الاغنيه الرمضانيه
احتفالا بفعاليه القرقيعان التي قدم فيها
الاطفال سلال الحلويات للزائرين
انا جايه هنا موسم رمضان
جايه اوزع قرقيعان وماما اخترت لي لبس
القرقيعان هذا
الملابس اشتريتها بمناسبه رمضان بدانا
قلنا القرقيعان وجيت يعني هنا نسوي
فعاليات بس وانا اشتريت عادي انا
ومن اجل القرقيعان تزين الاطفال باللباس
الرمضاني التراثي واحتفلوا بالالعاب
والانشطه المخصصه لهم انا جاي هنا عشان
اوزع قرقيعان
وانبسط والعب
وانبسطتوا وقسم الله خير ولعبت تسوق كل
شيء
وخذ عطوني قرقعان وخلصت وانبسطت والله جاي
هنا موسم رمضان عشان
قرقيعان
وعشان نستان نلعب ونجمع ايه نلعب صراحه
موسم رمضان احلى موسم مر علي
بالاشياء التراثيه وحسيت ان اليوم
فعاليات الاطفال وغيرها من الفعاليات
الاطفال وتوزيعات الحلا وكل شيء حلو لم
يقتصر الاحتفال بالقرقيعان خلال موسم
رمضان على تلك الاغاني او الالعاب فقط بل
حضرت العادات التراثيه كنقش الحنه لتزيين
ايادي الفتيات بنقشات تتناسب مع شهر رمضان
من الرياض شهد المتروك العربيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات